totally shocked by what's happened to
think that something so horrific could
happen again
to another mp
to another family
um
i'm scared and frightened and
yeah a real roller coaster emotions to
be honest my phone started going
straight away
my mum and dad my partner my friends you
know are you okay
and i was okay i was visiting a school
actually um
but
the shock
and the
feelings for us as a family obviously as
to what we went through and that another
family is having to go through that
again
it's horrific and it is hard to put into
words how that feels for me but
the the main people i'm thinking about
are david's family and his friends
and actually
the community that he represents and has
represented for such a long time and i
think that's the thing that people need
to understand this
is about a lot of people whose lives
will have been changed forever today
and you know i know
people still come up to me and talk to
me about where they were when joe was
killed and
their lives have just been changed and
it's so hard because we've got a job to
do
and i find myself now
you know working as a politician and
trying to help people and trying to do
good things for people and it's really
important that we get good people in
public life
but
this is the risk that we're all taking
you know and so many mps today will be
scared by this and my partner came home
and said i don't want you to do it
anymore
i don't because the next time that phone
goes it could be a different
conversation
so there's so many layers to this at the
heart of it david's family and friends
and
i know for them now that their lives
will never be the same again
they will think about this every single
day for the rest of their lives
and like i said even david's staff you
know so many of the people today who
have been out there trying to do the
right thing
trying to do a really important job in
public life
and
and then this happens and
it's
unbelievable that it can happen i still
can't believe this has happened
so it feels very raw for me and i know
from the messages i've been receiving
from politicians across the political
spectrum for them it is incredibly raw
but the main people that are on my mind
are david's family and friends and i
know
the roller coaster that they will now be
on and
there's so little that you can say
because
it's happened
so i mean what's it like trying to do
your job and being aware of your safety
safety is always on my mind everywhere i
go and everything i do and it was before
i became an mp but now more than ever
and i'm really well looked after by the
police the west yorkshire police have
been absolutely amazing
but you do think should i go there
should i do that and obviously you want
to be accessible you're a public servant
you're there to serve the public
and how can you do that when you don't
feel safe um
and how can you do it and be open and
accessible which is what i want to be as
an mp
when you know that there's a massive
risk involved with that i think that's
really really difficult so now i'm
thinking i'm meant to be going to a few
things this weekend do i go do i go
my family and friends are saying you
shouldn't go but i've got a job to do
and i totally understand mps and other
people in the public life who say look i
just want to do my job but ultimately
there are massive risks involved with
that now
so it is always there in your mind